work no longer pays what it used to
inflation is eroding our earnings and
Banks aren't passing on higher interest
rates to Savers
pensioners like Carol say their money
isn't working as hard as it used to I've
been trying to
create a financial buffer
and every time I get a little bit saved
something happens
so that's going to be at the moment the
cost of living crisis if I want to
actually have a life
I have to work
back in December 2021 the bank of
England's interest rate stood at just
0.1 percent with the average savings
rate on the High Street at 0.2 percent
but while the bank of England has since
hiked its main interest rate to four
percent
average savings rates among High Street
banks have only risen to 1.88 percent
it means that those with 30 000 pounds
of savings only stand to make 569 pounds
in interest each year that's less than
half of what they would have earned if
the rate Rises had been passed on in
full
retail banks have been quick to pass on
the bank of England's rate hikes to
mortgage holders but Savers haven't had
the same treatment it means the gap
between what banks charge borrowers and
pay Savers has widened helping to boost
their profits
and this amounts to billions of extra
pounds for the banks at the expense of
their customers politicians are calling
for change it is pretty Preposterous
that at a time when the bank of England
is raising rates uh that they're not
passing on that increase in rates to
their Savers and I think the way that we
develop a savings Habit in this country
again is if Savers feel that they're
being treated fairly by their Banks
but it's not just a question of fairness
the bank of England has been raising
rates to combat inflation if retail
Banks actually pass these on to Savers
it would achieve the central bank's aims
faster
by compelling Banks to uh to pay better
rates to Savers that would improve what
we call the transmission of monetary
policy and ultimately it is likely by
having monetary policy working better
the central bank will have to raise
rates less
banks are reaping the benefit
of low interest that crushed Bank
margins
some argue that if customers want better
returns they should shop around for
better deals
Sky News